voilà les nouvelles lunettes de réalité
mixte de Nubia l'idée c'est de
réinventer une interface homme machine
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
smartphones on veut plus avoir dans les
noms on veut plus de contraintes donc on
va passer soit par des lunettes
peut-être plus tard par des lentilles si
c'est possible en tout cas par des
lunettes parce qu'on peut avoir une
batterie on peut avoir des haut-parleurs
alors j'ai une copie en fait de l'écran
de mon smartphone sur branché par un
câble donc là je peux venir voir ce qui
se passe autour de moi avec un petit
écran et je peux imaginer des usages sur
la réalité augmentée pour la navigation
pour y avoir du contenu pour partager
pour les présentations pour avoir un
frontière pour plein de choses et
lorsque je vais vous raconter un peu
plus immersif et bien regardez je viens
positionner ça directement là c'est
aimanté ça se pose là je vois mon écran
devant moi ce que je vois est beaucoup
mieux je vais avoir des petites molettes
pour me dire régler ma vision ça c'est
des petits boutons pour régler le volume
parce que j'ai des haut-parleurs de
chaque côté je vais avoir des petits
boutons de ce côté là pour régler la
luminosité également on se parle ici de
lunettes qui font 79 g et lorsque vous
regardez vous avez un écran grand écran
de 120 pouces donc c'est vrai que c'est
quand même extrêmement immersif c'est la
neovision glace que vous imaginez est-ce
que vous projetez dans un futur à plus
avoir de smartphone dans les mains mais
avoir des lunettes qui viendrait
remplacer pour avoir une nouvelle
interface en machine marquez moi ça bien
évidemment dans les commentaires